when i called you that day it it scared
me it intimidated me
you had these two young kids in the back
and i thought god i'm so far away from
that
like i'm i i would be so scared if
somebody put two young kids in the back
of my car and said just
go and take them and feed them you know
it cut to like years later
the full circle story of irony is we
were both pregnant together at my
wedding
with like bumping bellies the only two
sober chicks there
and um i was so amazed by you being this
young
mother who was able to take all that on
and and did you how did you balance
work and motherhood at that point
because i was just trying to balance
work
and how did you do both yeah well
to be completely candid i was terrified
too i got pregnant when i was
22 years old um and i didn't know
how to balance uh work and motherhood
and we just you just do it you know
i i didn't know if i was gonna have
steady work too i wasn't a popular like
i
made movies but i hadn't you know
established
myself as someone who could demand that
it shoot close to my kid's school or you
know i didn't have any
real um power leverage within my
industry so
i think it was just like every other mom
trying to figure it out and dad out
there and partner and grandparent who's
raising a child
there's a lot of first of all compromise
you take the food out of your mouth the
clothes off your back
the sleep out of your life but every bit
of it
every bit of that sacrifice is truly
worth it
because you feel like that's what makes
me wake up
on a sunday is it's not movies or my job
it's my kids
[Music]
you